over the course of last week I've
realized that even though I've used so
many different earbuds the nothing ear
twos are one of my favorites for three
different reasons and in this video I'll
explain the positives as well as the
negative so you can make a good informed
choice if you should buy these now
nothing is a company that I really like
because they
a little bit differently they had plenty
of advertising that was done a little
bit differently a lot of hype build up
but I like the products because they
just look a little bit different they
have something special about them and
the same thing with the nothing here too
now these look very similar to the first
versions there's some small tweaks as
far as the design of the case is
slightly smaller but compared to
everything else that's out there these
stand out with their clear case design
along with having the white and even the
buds themselves having casings that are
translucent so you see some of the
components inside and I really
appreciate it even the packaging is a
little bit unique the way you tear off
the tab all the way around it and you
open them up and inside you get a short
but high quality USB type-c cable along
with some different ear tips now I use
the largest ones and wearing these for I
think up to four hours at a time until
the battery died out I had no issues
with Comfort whatsoever which I can't
say for a lot of other competitors so I
would say that Comfort is one of the
major pluses for these they fit my ears
really well and even though it's a
slightly looser fit even with the large
ear tips compared to some others they
did not come out of my ears for any
reason and with that it still felt like
I had a nice seal without too much
pressure now I did use them with active
noise cancellation on for most of the
time and we'll talk about that in just a
bit and that leads to that roughly four
hours of battery life which is lower
than a lot of the competitors but the
case holds about five extra charges
which is more than average and that is
nice and it also can charge up about
eight hours of charge time in about 10
minutes which is really nice now even
though the case doesn't look like it has
Qi wireless charging it actually does
have a coil built in so that is great I
truly enjoy having wireless charging
it's very convenient and other than that
I do like the shape and the fact that
there's a little indent in here it just
makes me kind of play around with them
it's a little fidget uh kind of a design
and then inside you guys see the buds
right there they're nice and easy to
know which one goes where they magnetize
in and they're easy to access which I
can't say for a lot of the other earbuds
with that the size is fairly decent I do
wish it was a little bit smaller as far
as the shape instead of this square but
it's not too thick so even though I do
notice them in my pocket it's not a
major big bump that gets annoying the
other thing I want to mention is that
even though it's only been a week I am
already noticing scratches on the case
and I've been pretty easy with them
other than one drop onto carpet so I'm
guessing that in a month or a couple
months this is going to be fairly
scratched up but with that that the
magnetic closure in the hinge is nice
and high quality so when I did drop it
they didn't fall out onto the buds
themselves like I mentioned I really
like the design not only because it's
translucent but the shape is nice it
fits into most ears really well and even
the actual ear tip is a more of kind of
like an oval instead of being round
makes it slightly Slimmer and it makes
it definitely comfortable when it's in
your ear and even though I don't think
that they have pressure vents I don't
get a lot of pressure having these in my
ears even with the active noise
cancellation now one of my favorite
things are the controls you have these
stems that come down and you click in
order to pause resume you can
multi-click to skip tracks you can even
click and hold in order to do other
settings and I think this is by far the
best way to control earbuds especially
if you have a stem instead of tapping
them like you have on a lot of other
ones now in that app you have a bunch of
different settings and some of which are
surprising for a 149 dollar earbuds
there's in-ear detection personalized
Inc which we'll talk about low lag mode
for gaming high quality lhdc audio codec
and personalized sound profile along
with dual connection which is really
cool you can connect to two different
devices and then when you get off your
phone and turn something on your laptop
for example it will automatically start
playing from there you have an ear tip
fit test and find my earbuds now when we
go out in the main menu you see the
battery life of both of your buds along
with the case there's also LED in here
that will give you that information of
course you can customize the controls
like we talked about and there is a
built-in equalizer now personally I
didn't mess around with it I bumped up
the treble a little bit but even the
default sounded really good to me now
there's also a personalized sound
profile which I appreciate now for me it
didn't make that big of a difference but
I think it really depends on your sound
preferences and your ear shape how much
of a difference it would make but it's
great that it's there now with that
let's talk about active noise
cancellation I was really surprised how
well these did now they're not the best
on the market but they are up there and
they do have personalized ink where it
will tune it for your ears and maybe for
the environment and it did make a small
but noticeable difference for me now you
can also manually change that if you
don't want as much which is really nice
to have if you're more sensitive to that
so overall the active noise cancellation
is really good for that price point now
what isn't good is the transparency mode
while it's not the worst that I've heard
it is not great at all and I think that
has something to do with the microphones
that are built in there now when I made
some calls the people didn't really have
any issues hearing me but when I
recorded using my phone's recording app
the quality was pretty bad go ahead and
take a listen now I'm guessing that's
because the microphones just aren't
picking up the high-ends as well so
here's a recording from the nothing ear
two now thankfully the sound quality
makes up for that because these things
sound fantastic the original ones were
not that great sounding even after
updates but these ones they made some
changes to the internal shape they did a
lot of tuning and it sounds fantastic
now when I compared them to my other
earbuds in some songs they didn't do as
well but surprisingly in heavy songs
they'll have a lot of instruments like
rock these actually beat them out and I
was just shocked by that now with that
said these also have a very natural
sound tuning so it's not too boomy the
highs aren't pushed up too much they are
actually closer to reference compared to
most earbuds so you get a very balanced
natural sound and over the last week
I've really enjoyed listening to me I
didn't feel like I was missing out as
far as sound quality to my earbuds that
cost to about twice as much now the only
kind of complaint that I have is that I
wish they did get a little bit louder
not that they are quiet I personally
just like Extremely Loud sounds and that
is not good for my ears so I think when
you turn these up they get to loud
enough without damaging your ears maybe
even slightly louder than that but even
though they are louder than some of the
other earbuds that I've used that cost
more I still wish I had a little bit of
extra oomph sometimes especially with
tracks that are quieter that you're
listening to so with all of that said I
think these are the best earbuds you can
buy for 100 149 dollars they are unique
they look very cool the active noise
cancellation is good and the sound
quality is really really good so if
you're looking for something that stands
out that has a little bit of character
and that still has great features for a
good price point I would say these are
one of my favorites so thank you guys
for watching go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those videos right over there this is
a Max and I'll see you in the next one
foreign